وقفتنا الثانيه مع الاقتصاد في هذه
التغطيه الخاصه مع زميلتنا العزيزه فاطمه
الزهراء الضاوي كضيفه ضمن صباح العربيه
يسعد هالصباح يا فاطمه الزهراء صباح الخير
نادين صباح الخير سهام هالمره احنا معكم
بست واحنا اكيد منورتينا في هذا الاستوديو
ولما نحكي كمان عن قسم الاقتصاد عنصر
اساسي فاطمه الزهره الضاوي فيه بس اسمحيلي
فاطمه انا بس سؤال سريع هيك قبل ما هي
بنلاحظ انه في عالمنا العربي في كتير
مذيعين اخبار في كتير قنوات بسملاحظ انه
مذيعين اقتصادي قلال هل مهمتكم اصعب
والسوق محدود
مليون بالمئه نادين مهمتنا اصعب لانه
تغطيه الاخبار الاقتصاديه
لقينا لها وهو انه اللي بينجح يغطي
الاخبار اسواق المال لازم يكون عنده خلفيه
اقتصاديه وبالتالي هذا بيبرر انه كلي انا
وزملائي جايين من خلفيه بنوك وخل خلفيه
دراسه بالجامعات والجامعات الاقتصاديه
وغيرها على كل بالطبع هذا موضوع طويل
يمكن ناخذ فيه ظروف قبلها قبل الحديث حول
الجانب اخر بعيد عن جديه الارقام ومؤشرات
اسواق المال والاسهم نتحول ونتوقف اولا مع
مجموعه من الاجواء العفاويه اللطيفه في
الاقتصادم الزهراء
على الشركات اللي عندها نوع من ربحيه
معينه اعلى من غيرها
[ضحك]
للموضوع انا مرشح حدا غيري عم يعطس
لكن فعلا من حيث قيامه
مليون درهم عفوا 290 مليون درهم ابوظبي
على ثبات
المشاهد ما بيعرفوا
نادين خلينا نسلم عنك شويه
ايضا نسمع ايضا اخبار عن هذه الشركه
بوبيان
اذا يبدو انه صار في بعض
الفيدرالي قد يكون رفع الفائده ب 375 نقطه
اجماليا منذ مارس
نهايه مدى ضخامه التجديد النقد الذي
شهدناه في هذه الدوره الحاليه مدى ضخامه
التجديد النقد الذي شهدناه في هذه الدوره
الحاليه بالنسبه لي طبعا نحن ننتظر ايضا
من بين المواقفته كانت خلال لقاءاتنا مع
بعض الضيوف والمحللين فاطمه
بالطبع كان في ردود واجابات بعضهم مفاجئه
وغير متوقعه نادين واستهام تماما مثل لقاء
زميلي ناصر الطيبي مع رجل الاعمال المصري
سميح ساويرس
وبعد هذه الجائحه كيف تاثر صافي ثروتك
في ظل هذه هذه الانتكاسه
يعني
عماره وجاه زلزال
هو زلزال حقيقه استاذ سميح
هل هل فقدنا الاتصال مع سيد سميح
لربما لن نعرف
قطع الخط الان نسمعك اتفضل فكرناك انت
قطعت الخط لما سالناك عن صافي الثروه
في تصريحات اخرى حول رفع بخمسين نقطه اساس
في اجتماع المقبل للمركزي الاوروبي اللي
هو بمنتصف ديسمبر ما بعرف
يبدو بانه الفريق خلصت المباراه
والمنتخب السعودي اذا يفوز على الارجنتين
اثنين واحد في افتتاح مباراتي بكاس العالم
مبروك للمنتخب السعودي اذا
على امل ان تنتج نصف مليون خاصه خلال
الخمس سنوات القادمه الجزيره بالذكر ان
الانتقال الى عمل الروبوتات في الزراعه قد
يخفض تكاليف العماله الى النصف كما انه
سيخفض تكاليف الطاقه الى
كثره عنا من برنامج